the football poll question is how we're
going to start our conversation with our
friend from the mmqb and sports
illustrated albert brewer back here on
the rich housing show how are you albert
i'm good i'm good i drive a ten and two
and only in inclement weather though
okay so
like when it's like raining i i find
myself doing that like you know when
you just
it's raining hard enough or it's snowing
i guess you guys don't experience that
much out there but like where it just
feels like your car
but you don't have full control like
then i'll go ten and two but normally i
don't i'll admit that but rain out here
is akin to snow
um albert right to the point where like
if
pre pandemic sitting there in uh staples
and uh tip off of a laker game and
there's really only a quarter of the
place filled up it's because it was
raining outside i'm serious like i've
actually white knuckle conditions out
there right yeah well no question about
it what yeah i mean like have you have
you tried like have you lost your
ability to drive in snow having been out
there for 20 years now oh no man and
actually it's out driving out here is
better coming from the east coast is as
brockman will tell you
tell
tell mr breer what your olympic sport
you would have gold medaled in uh if
this was an actual olympic sport my
olympic sport is being in the far left
lane and crossing over four lanes of
traffic to make the exit under a quarter
mile which is an expert
and and i'm i'm also i'm i'd also be a
medalist in the
like when it when the highway reduces a
lane riding the extra lane all the way
up all the way to the left that works
here in los angeles because you know uh
everybody's kindly lines up to leave a
right hand right lane exit in the right
lane oh no not us not us that comes in
handy but we shouldn't give up our
tricks
don't tell people mighty or 1090 in
southern california we should not give
up our tricks i mean probably you
probably like really easily tell who's
from like the i-95 corridor between
washington and boston out there right
probably really easy by the way we've
now done a seven-minute parallel parking
segment with bobby canavali in the first
three minutes of a chat with albert
breer on on driving in traffic
how would you answer our poll question
of the day football wise albert the
quarterback recently drafted in the top
five in the nfl
which one's going to have a better 2021
the choices are give them to them chris
brockman i know this is your job i don't
mean to
still you know i should stay in my lane
to use that phrase
yeah yeah better 2021 albert sam darnold
zach wilson tua or joe burrow
sam darnold zach wilson tua or joe
burrow
uh
that's a good one that's a really good
one i
i want to say
joe burrow because i think he's the best
player
um but i would say like tua
probably has the best situation of those
four right like the most infrastructure
around him the most built up team
um so
i mean give me burrow just because i
think burro is pretty special um but i
mean man that's tough that's a really
good question because i i think sam is
gonna play better too in carolina and
mostly because i think they're gonna ask
less of him you know like they're gonna
they're gonna put it on christian
mccaffrey to carry that offense and so
sam darnold's going to be able to play
in a way i think that's different than
he's ever played before well i mean the
question about tua that you know we had
jeff darlington now on an hour number
one to talk about his report that brian
flores felt compelled to address charles
robinson's yahoo report that uh that
deshaun watson was on their radar screen
and they were front runners to go get
him in a trade that eventually didn't
happen that he he felt compelled to
address his locker room on that too as
the guy
is what is the evaluation of tua and i
i'm mystified as to why the dolphins
would be willing like obviously desean
watson with no baggage that's a
no-brainer but to to kick the tires on
trying to get watson now
without even sending to a way in a trade
in that trade i don't understand it i
don't i don't get it what is the
evaluation of tool from what you're
hearing based on uh this preseason in
training yeah
so like you know what and i i think i'm
going to reference what you're
what you're what you're insinuating here
is that if they traded for desean
tua wouldn't necessarily be a part of
that deal to go to houston and i think
that the
my understanding of that is the driver
there wouldn't be the dolphins so much
it was as it would be the texans and
um this is something that i think is
kind of an interesting piece to the
whole idea that deshaun watson could be
traded and um and whether or not it
happens you know now in october november
december um you know i was told pretty
strongly by several people not to assume
that some other team's quarterback is
going to be viewed by the texans as an
asset
and so like you know i think you know
what i'm what i'm
what was conveyed to me is
nick casario the general manager there
might rather have an extra draft pick
over
a to a a a drew lock as a sam darnold or
jalen hurts you know who'll be the four
quarterbacks with the teams that you
know i think have been most connected to
sean over the last few weeks so that's
you know where that is the evaluation
too i think the jury is still very much
out and i mean i think like just having
as weird a rookie year as he did where
they put him in and generally once you
put your first round quarterback in you
don't take them out yet the dolphins
wound up pulling tua back out
um you know i think the question really
with tua is
like he was just okay last year and
physically there's nothing that really
stands out about him
and the really interesting thing about
this rich is
like go back and look at the last 10
years of quarterbacks who have come into
the nfl right like the first round
quarterbacks coming to the nfl
how many guys have come into the nfl
where you could look at them and say
there's not something special about them
physically whether they're an incredible
athlete have a huge arm they're
physically huge
like the guys who've really made it josh
allen patrick mahomes justin herbert but
the guys that have really flashed carson
wentz
like how many of those guys aren't
special physically
um
and i'm not talking about the bradies of
the world because that's a long time ago
talk about guys who came into the league
over the last 10 years how hard is it to
fight it's really hard like jared goff
derek carr like yeah like those guys
made it but were those guys ever
considered like top 10 players at the
position
right and if that's what you're shooting
for
and you're looking at it and you're
questioning can tua get there not can he
be a competent quarterback can he get
there and then the opportunity to go out
and get it deshaun watson comes along i
think that's sort of part of the
evaluation it's not so much that tua
isn't going to be able to get out of his
own way as an nfl quarterback it's you
know how far are we going to be able to
really take this with him albert breer
here on the rich eisen show
the
conversation coming out of jacksonville
today twofold one the saints are gonna
play their first game there this year
because of hurricane ida it's gonna be
uh saints versus packers there and we'll
have i guess time to talk about that but
the conversation is based on urban meyer
saying that the team considered
vaccination status and whether
somebody should stay or not and there's
such a huge to do about that the players
association says that they're going to
open an investigation and the thing i
don't quite understand about it is
corporate america writ large from from
the nfl uh corporately
and what uh other other
corporations with at t we're on their
campus right here is another one fox
uh for their news division as well uh
mandating people to be vaccinated i just
uploaded my vaccinated my vaccination
card during the commercial break
actually because i did not know how to
do it again
um
what's the disconnect why why is there
such a hullabaloo about this
albert um it's because the players are
unionized and the rest of the nfl
employees most of them are you know and
so uh the league the teams can put in
protocols that basically require
all their employees to get vaccinated
except for the players and the players
that has to be negotiated with the union
and so i understand why the union is you
know coming out and you know i guess
kind of rattling cages on that
that said i mean what urban is
referencing here
was created by the union right like in
part they negotiated those protocols
with the league and they knew it was
going to be hard for an unvaccinated
player
to operate like a normal nfl player in
2021 as a result of it and
you know they knew that they were
creating an environment where
decisions roster decisions realistically
we're going to have to be made on
certain guys and i'm not talking about
you know who your starting quarterback
is or who you know one of your starting
receivers are but like once we get to a
point in the roster where you're talking
about the 40th guy or the 45th guy in
the roster like of course yeah like if
two guys are even at that point like are
you going to take the guy who can walk
around freely and isn't randomly going
to have to disappear for five days
because something went wrong like
over the guy who you know is going to be
subject to those rules of course you are
so you know like i i just i understand
what the union is doing here but i also
you know i think it's important to point
out they were part of creating these
rules and i think these rules are
designed to make ever to keep everybody
safe and
um yeah i always think it's silly like
now look like i
i have a pretty good handle on who urban
is and i think urban sometimes can be a
little unaware of certain things around
him and so i'm not sure like he really
understood that he could
come out and say what everybody is
saying behind closed doors
um you know but like i i just don't know
what the point of having an argument
over this is it's like it is where it is
like it's
it's going to be harder for certain guys
to make teams it's going to be harder
for certain street free agents to get
picked up because they're unvaccinated
that's part of the equation here i mean
they
through the rules the nfl and nfl pa
have very heavily incentivized getting
the shots
well and and you know belichick was
asked in new england whether that played
a role in the
uh release of cam newton he said no
um he did talk about the efficacy of the
vaccine which was an interesting
response
but uh the question about cam is is you
know
did he ask for his release what do we
know because obviously belichick would
not allow anything on that front either
what do you hear about cam's
i don't think i i i don't think cam
asked for his release i like and i i
don't know for sure but just you know
based on a few things i have heard
putting two and two together
um i don't think this is a you know a a
a result of him asking out
i think everybody sort of knew the score
here which is cam was either going to be
there as a starter or he wasn't going to
be on the team at all and so i think
when they make the decision to go with
with mac um like most other teams that
have first round quarterbacks then the
priority becomes what can we do to
create the best environment for our
rookie quarterback to perform as a
rookie and
um you know i think
a a huge part of it is what sort of
resources can you put in the room for
him that's why brian hoyer is going to
be back on the roster maybe by the end
of the day because he'll be a great
resource having all the background in
the system that he does for mac jones
and the other thing is i like i think
you want to avoid a situation where
there's going to be something hanging
over the rookie
and bottom line is if you've got a
player the statue of cam newton standing
on the sideline
like you have to and this isn't cam's
fault but like you have to worry about
like you know the fact that like hey if
he has a couple games where he throws
you know three picks and then four picks
like there's going to be people calling
and saying there's gonna be people
calling for for cam to go on the game
and it could create a problem internally
for you and so
i just think that it was never
i i don't think cam was ever going to be
on the patriots roster as a backup and i
think that's more about supporting the
rookie quarterback than anything else i
don't think it has anything to do with
anything cam did right or wrong i just
think it's you know when you when you
decide okay we're going with the rookie
we're going with matt jones
like then you have to make sure that you
create the best environment for them and
i actually think it's like very akin um
rich to the dolphins letting ryan
fitzpatrick go after this year
because when you make the decision
you're going to go with tua you can't
have like everything that happened last
year with fitz hanging over him
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
uh you mentioned to us a couple fridays
ago a terrific insight
about how um in chicago you were hearing
about andy dalton's ability to
communicate a play
to each position group within the huddle
based on the verbiage of the play
being specifically in the play call for
that position group and justin
fields was just blurting it out because
he's memorizing stuff and that's part of
the maturation process that matt neggie
wants to work on
and and
now we're waiting to see
uh how long dalton's going to be in
there because he's going to be in there
and we're waiting to see
how long justin fields needs to stay in
the maturation you know process
because belichick's now going with his
guy right off the bat and i'm wondering
how that all plays together
in chicago prior to this week one andy
dalton start and how long that's going
to last based on your hearing right now
i think it's going to be really i i
think one thing that everybody can pay
attention to it's going to be a tell
who dresses for that sunday night opener
against the rams okay i i think it's
this is one thing that like i think is a
nuance to every one of these situations
where a rookie isn't starting right off
the bat that people need to pay
attention to
like if you are truly in it to preserve
your rookie and to not play your rookie
and you don't think he's ready and what
he needs is a red shirt you know what
you do rich you don't dress him for the
game you you you you throw somebody else
on the roster as the backup and you have
the rookie watching from the press box
because you do not want to put them in
the game that's what the packers did
last year with jordan love jordan love i
believe still hasn't dressed for a
regular season game crazy as that sounds
as an nfl player
so like i think a lot of justin field's
readiness to get out there we're going
to see it on whether and whether or not
they decide to dress him
for the regular season opener against
the rams because generally if you carry
three quarterbacks in the roster and the
bears are
two of the three quarterbacks stress and
the third one doesn't uh
um so the bears are either going to
dress fields and not foals dress foals
and not be able to address both of them
but if they dress field that tells me
they feel pretty good about where he's
at and so
you know i i know a lot's been done to
try to accelerate the process
and you know part of it is learning the
verbiage like we talked about it was
last week when we talked about this
um and now it sort of moves into a
different phase where justin's going to
have to do some of that learning on his
own because he's going to run the scout
team this is another story that i think
is going to be really interesting too
because
and and i know i'm being long-winded
here but i know that there's something
there's something really interesting
here to parallel to patrick mahomes in
2017 please
one of the things that mac maggie was
most impressed by when he was the
chief's offensive coordinator in 2017
working with alex smith and patrick
mahomes mahomes wasn't playing
mahomes ran the scout team during the
week so he wasn't running the chief's
offense during the week right like so
he'd go in and he'd be running the
raiders off into the chargers offense or
whoever they were playing that week
so after practice every day every single
day he would stay out there for an extra
half hour 45 minutes
and he would do it so he could run the
chief's offensive play he'd do this on
his own
and what he did was he would take
receivers and running backs and tight
ends but he would never take tyree kill
he would never take
a kareem hunt he would never take travis
kelsey with him why
well he didn't take those guys with him
because he knew those were alex's guys
and i do not want to upset the ecosystem
of this team
and he did it on his own and the two the
the coaches were so impressed by that
and so this is part of like matt's whole
i think evaluation of justin fields is
now that he's out of the quarterback
competition for now at least what's he
gonna do like how is he going to treat
that time and i think having seen
patrick mahomes do that
like that's a huge part of why mahomes
were so ready in 18 and when's the mvp
will justin handle this the way that
patrick mahomes does i think if he does
and now all of a sudden you get to week
four week five the team's struggling the
offensive line can't product protect
protect dalton then maybe there's a
chance for fields to get in there so let
me let me voice the bears fan here
because i think they're gonna have a say
personally yep is that okay the
evaluation of mac jones was completed
obviously yesterday by new england the
evaluation of trevor lawrence allegedly
was evaluated and completed by last week
and zach willison's evaluation was
completed prior to draft day right
and the evaluation of trey lance
technically is still going on he's he's
banged up right now but i think we know
that shanahan's going to at least have
some plays for him in the playbook yep a
bears fan hearing all this this sounds
very diligent and it sounds very very um
what's the word for it uh careful okay
it sounds diligent careful it sounds
responsible that's the word for it it
sounds responsible
but come on like
right i mean like it's not like the kid
played for a division three school in
ohio he played for the ohio state and i
know i'm talking your language here so
i just don't know how long we can keep
on evaluating him it's
it's certainly when you you see how many
kids in their second second year third
year are more advanced because of what
they did get in their first year
right so that's what i'm scared you know
yeah and i understand what you're saying
and that's why i think like some of this
isn't going to depend on andy dalton
himself okay
and
like you know if you look at the history
of it and and i'm talking going back you
know 20 years right like i've done
research on this over you know and i'm
sure people out there have seen the
chart that i tweet out from time to time
there was a
i would say a paradigm shift in 2008
with matt ryan and joe flacco and it was
because those two those teams didn't
just start those guys from from the
beginning from week one those guys won
with those guys the falcons made the
playoffs coming out of just a
ridiculously horrible michael vick
situation in year one with matt ryan and
the ravens that year got to the afc
championship game with joe flacco
since then you've seen more and more
teams going with rookies early okay and
i think since then there's been 41
quarterbacks to go in the first round um
of those 41 only three were true red
shirts jake locker um patrick mahomes
and jordan love you wanna know what all
three of those teams had in common
all three of those teams contended all
the way to the end of the season two of
them made the playoffs so to keep the
rookie off the field you needed
confident quarterback play those three
teams got it from matt hasselbeck alex
smith and aaron rodgers but you also
needed to be contending deep into the
season and so like my answer to what
you're saying
is
this all looks good this all seems
responsible it only works as a team's a
contender if the team struggles early on
there will be a lot of pressure on
everybody in that building to get justin
fields on the field and my guess is
you'll see them sooner rather than later
if the team
you know what is on pace to win 11 12
games and andy dalton's playing well
we're talking about something else so i
think a lot of this rides on
a lot of this rides on not just the
success of andy dalton but what the team
around him is doing
well it's first game is right up the
road here in the the stadium um in the
new stadium where the super bowl is
being played and it's a huge game uh
because it's the first time with fans
here in los angeles for that stadium for
a regular season game it's such a huge
game that brockman's not even going to
sell his his tickets to somebody else
he's planning on going so that's how big
the game is albert if you want to put
that nugget in your next column i heard
you got a nice new office up there too
huh well i'll move i'm checking it out
next week i have not been there yet my
the swan song to the old culver city
studio is tuesday we're doing the season
opening show tuesday honestly like if i
was local i would definitely come up for
that man like that's crazy that i mean
like it's gonna be weird the next time
i'm in l.a and if i drive by they're not
seeing the signs and everything you know
yeah we're moving into the new the right
next to the new stadium there's a ribbon
cutting next wednesday and then our
first show's there from thursday kickoff
then sunday game day morning i haven't
been there yet i can't wait to see it
are you guys outside is the set going to
be outside or in no it's inside it's
inside but as you know over the last
several years uh for the demo set which
is the phrase used in television where
we demo plays on a football field that's
basically like uh eight yards by eight
yards and it's made to look bigger by
the shot there the football demo field
is outside and it is huge and the
stadium's in the background that i know
can't wait that's great
can't wait and it's crazy uh there
there's the albert breerwing they i
don't know so they're thinking they're
thinking of you still albert all my all
my contributions there well actually
albert i will say hey if they want if
they want to put a plaque up i i think i
can carve out some time to sit for that
like you know or maybe maybe even a bus
i will say this albert
i could i could find some time in my
schedule to sit for that i do i will say
this that um i was not i was not on the
zoom the the nfl media group uh on air
um
symposium zoom
um because the rich eisen show is on
during it two days ago but i knew what
was going on because the number of texts
that went around from everybody that you
know saying where's breer because you
were such a star of those year in and
year out oh yeah
there was one where i didn't hold my
feelings back no that was great and it's
still we're still talking about it
albert but uh the bottom line is we're
thinking of you and no we miss you
you're the best all right well i
appreciate that i miss you guys too take
care that's albert everybody the mmqb
senior nfl reporter hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here